hey guys welcome back to brand-new baby
we are back on 400 in today's Thursday
tips to recap day as always so let's go
over today's bedroom we got some decent
info to talk about as well as a December
roadmap for what's gonna be going on in
next month so let's get started with
today's news so first up is the sale of
the week now these now obviously if you
haven't been paying attention the devs
have been doing a sale every single week
on certain items
today's sale the week is going to be on
the salt and the drinking emote that
called down the hash and rub salt in the
wound I believe there are now 7,000
steel instead of 10 K for this week so
definitely go grab that if you do enjoy
those emotes I believe they're available
for all characters except the woman I
believe I could be wrong though stuff is
the December roadmap and this was talked
about
so some notable things are the content
of the week and the weekly arcade quests
are still going to be being added every
week which is really good more content
for us to play carousel of death is live
right now from November 29th to December
5th so definitely go play that if you
enjoy some carousel of death a double xp
fest will be December 7 to December 10th
so definitely hop onto get that double
xp I'll definitely be hopping on to get
some of that as well to end this there's
also a big question mark on the 20th of
December I'm not really entirely sure
but this is the dev said that they're
not going to talk about it so start your
speculation now I'm going to assume it's
executions although every single
execution always come out the Thursday
before the season starts so the week
before season 8 came out they came out
with the season 8 executions as you guys
are already aware so it most likely
won't be executions but you never know
that could switch it up sometime could
be a showcase of new of the new heroes
it could be anything on signatures new
content stuff like that I love to know
your guys thoughts in the comments below
and what you guys think this big
question mark is but keep your eyes
peeled on the stream for December 20th
because and keep an eye on the channel
because I will gladly recap whatever
this thing happens to be on top of that
patch 2.03 is releasing on December 13th
I'm assuming either next week's dev
stream or the week after that we're
gonna be getting some info on what 2.03
is so be on the lookout for that
and then lastly the faction war will end
on the 28th of December now I'm assuming
there will be an off season break of
maybe a week or two and then season 9
will release around January 14th so this
is just speculation not an actual date
but I'm assuming it's somewhere around
mid to early January's where
is gonna release next up is the new
content of the week and this is called
grasping thorn it's pretty cool effects
this for 5,000 steel if you do want to
grab it so grab while you can and while
that's plying I'm gonna be talking about
this little Q&A session that the
developers did a very quick thing and a
few things that I would like to include
and sum up is that they're possibly
gonna be adding more steel and XP to
Arcade Mode because it is pretty
lackluster for the amount of skill that
you need to defeat that more types of
stuff for matchmaking this being a
closer level and closer rep stuff like
that so you can get paired up with
people that are actually your rank
instead of other people that are way too
above it or way too low for you
there is also two ideas for adding
different colored effects so for example
the arcade effect I believe it's called
the Crimson conquest people were saying
that they want to change the color of it
not that red is a bad color but people
said that they prefer like a blue or I
go a yellow or green or stuff like that
and on top of that people mentioned an
execution and an emote wheel so when you
press the button for the emo it will
come up with a wheel of emotes or a
wheel of executions depending on where
you are and you can do any of them so
instead of doing two or four whatever
your character has you could do a lot
more which is pretty cool now sadly for
both of these though these are not a
huge priority when it most likely won't
come to the game as cool as the sound
and they also do not plan to add new
materials at the moment for the
character so golden bronze those ones
are gonna stay but nothing with platinum
and anything higher than that that's
just because they have to add a whole
new thing especially for the emotes and
the colors effects for the hair and
beards so someone else mentioned that
four colors of hair and beard sadly this
will obviously come to the game because
this will have a whole new interface
similar to how signatures just game in
the game and they'll need to make
changes to the old headgear so that they
can actually have beards or hair that
you can see so so it'll actually be
useful so that problem if that even does
release it won't be for a long time same
thing with the execution and emo will
it's not a huge priority and same thing
with the materials it's also not a huge
priority so sadly we won't be getting in
these things in the future if at all the
devs also talked about year of the
Harbinger I mentioned it in the not so
distant future that they will be
showcasing new heroes my guess is that
it's going to be a little bit before
season 8 ends or a little bit after
season a ends is usually I mean I've
been doing this for a long time so
usually they do it like a little bit
after sometimes different a little bit
after a little bit before it all changes
so hopefully around the
ending of season 8 we're gonna be
getting some decent info maybe a teaser
to thrown in there about the new heroes
a new map and stuff like that so I'm
very excited the question of the day
guys since this is going to be the end
of the vid I hope you guys did enjoy but
the question of the day to day is gonna
be what do you guys think about year of
the Harbinger what do you guys think is
gonna be coming in that in terms of
heroes and maps obviously in my
thumbnail for last week was the big
screen it's this huge ass hammer lots of
yellow background a lot of it blown up
stuff in the back I'm thinking it's
gonna be a huge heavy character as
always but in terms of what faction what
do you think it's gonna be or what do
you want to add into season 9 that you
think would be beneficial to the game or
do you think would just be cool anyway
so the looks and her thoughts in the
comments below
start a discussion with that big guys
like the V if I do enjoy subscriber for
new I cover the informational side a
foreigner that being balance changes
hero updates patch notes leaks
information new events all that stuff
about for honor I cover the
informational side of that so hopefully
you guys do stick around with that my
two most recent videos will be on screen
if you guys do want to check that out
with the guys hope you have a great
yesterday figure for us in the video and
peace out
[Music]